today's one minute monday is do
something different as entrepreneurs we
get locked into a routine right you with
the same thing for breakfast you go to
work you do the same thing every day you
get stale you get stuck in the same
boring routine and what's going to
happen quickly is it going to plateau
you're going to get to this point where
you're not seeing any growth and say why
can't I bust through why can't I make it
big why can't I get to my goal why can't
I get to where I want to go it's because
you're doing the same thing every single
day you need to try something different
even if it doesn't make sense for your
business even if you have no idea why
you're doing this thing find something
that excites you and do it because I
guarantee you're going to learn
something from it you're going to get
re-energized you're going to find new
passion you're going to pour that into
your business and it's going to help you
break through the plateau that you're
facing try something different believe
those are watching give it a thumbs up
leave a comment subscribe to the channel
I'll see you soon